Texture compression is another useful thing to consider here.
So by default we're DXT1 and on DX11.
But there are a few different texture compression settings you can choose from.
Again these can be found from double clicking the texture in your content browser
and depending on its use and how you want it to be compressed
there are a series of compression settings here for you to decide.
So whether it's a normal map or if it's a UI element
generally you probably wouldn't want UI elements being compressed as much.
So Unreal is trying to give you some affordances for what this texture is being used for
and therefore under the hood it can decide on the compression of that texture.
And then we've got texture groups as well.
So depending on the level of detail you want inside of your texture
you can group the textures and also when you set them to groups
you can change textures on a per group basis under the hood.
So for example if you say okay group all these textures into this UI element
or group all these textures into the vehicle element
when you're trying to scale settings under the hood
you know that they're being affected for that entire group.
So it's a nice way to kind of set up the group
so that everything's categorized into its own bucket
and then depending what you want to dial up and dial down
those will then affect everything within that group.
So very useful to consider when trying to make these optimizations.